(lively piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked.
Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are,
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(uptempo music)
(upbeat music)
- My job at the beginning at
least is a little simplified
because of the talks
you've heard from already
especially from Rick and from Wieland.
As you all are well aware,
the human brain is the
largest among primates,
living primates,
but I just wanted to emphasize
it's not the largest mammal brain.
Elephants and whales and
cetaceans have larger
and also more highly
folded cerebral cortices.
But in terms of brain number
in the cerebral cortex,
neuron number, humans have
the largest total number.
And so, my area of interest
similar to Wieland's is
one of the more obvious
features of human brain
is its size and the number of cells.
and that brings us right to the issue of
where they all come from
which has been as you hear
a sort of an interesting
problem or a central problem
for many of us.
The developmental stages are clearly
where we'll find the
answer to how that happens
and in my lab we've been looking
at human brain development
through the second trimester
which is when most cortical
neurons are developed.
And a cross-section through
the developing cortex
looks very different
in humans than it does
for example in mouse
which is the animal system
that most neuroscientists
have used to study
early stages of brain development.
So this is the cross-section of the mouse
and you heard from Wieland
very beautifully how there are
apical progenitors which
we call radial glia
shown here in red marked by Sox2,
one of the transcription
factors that they express.
And their daughter cells are these
intermediate progenitors that line up
right above them in the
subventricular zone.
And the beginning, the middle
and the end of neurogenesis in the mouse
looks just like that.
In the human it starts out very similarly.
There are radial glial cells
and intermediate progenitors
forming these two layers
but then very rapidly
the subventricular zone
undergoes this enormous
expansion that you've heard about
and becomes an outer
subventricular zone shown here.
And all of these colors represent
cells that are cycling.
They're producing daughter cells.
You may notice the
ventricular zone at this stage
becomes very small.
And so the majority of cortical
neurons at these stages
almost certainly are
coming from this zone,
not from the ventricular zone.
And moreover this isn't
the end of neurogenesis,
this is halfway through gestation week 17,
when the middle layers are being formed.
So the middle and upper cortical layers
are presumably being generated
by the cells in this
outer subventricular zone.
But the actual nature of those progenitors
really hadn't been studied,
and so we looked at it
in a variety of ways.
First I want to show you
how dynamic this area is.
In this case we're looking
at the outer subventricular
zone in a slice culture
where we've labeled just the
progenitor cells in green.
So there are neurons that you don't see
but the progenitors are highly dynamic.
And we look at them more carefully we find
two classes and one that
I really wanna emphasize
is this one.
It's a radial glia-like cell.
It has this process that
goes up to the pial surface
which is the basal fiber
but it doesn't have an apical
contact with the ventricle,
the way the epithelial cells
or the ventricular apical radial glia do.
Otherwise it looks just
like a radial glial cell.
It stains with all the markers
that you normally would
see in radial glial cells,
and if you backfill the
surface of the cortex
with a label like this, the Dil crystal,
it fills the fibers of these cells
that end in cell bodies in
the outer subventricular zone.
These cells hadn't been
described at the time
and so we call them outer subventricular
radial glial like cells or oRG cells,
and as you heard Wieland
calls them basal radial glial.
They're the same cell type
and they're enriched it turns out
in the human developing brain.
Now we've looked at them dynamically
and we're struck by a behavior
that hadn't been seen before.
These are four of the
cells that are labeled
in one slice of cortex.
And as they divide you may notice how they
sort of jump and divide,
and if you didn't notice
it in those images
I hope you'll be able to
see it in this single cell.
Because as they go through M-phase,
the actual cytokinesis
stage when they divide,
they jump first and then
undergo this cell division
or cytokinesis.
Very distinctive behavior that
hadn't been described before
and so we called it mitotic
somal translocation, MST.
And it was one of the defining
features of these cells
because there were no specific markers
that we could use to distinguish them
from the traditional
ventricular radial glia.
But when we look for them in other species
and this is in the mouse,
we found them there as well.
And if you watch this cell,
it's what we call now a mouse
outer radial glial cell.
And you see it goes through a little jump,
much more modest than the human cells.
It has this basal fiber
and it's located in
the subventricular zone
if the mouse had a subventricular zone.
So these cells are present
in small numbers in the mouse
and are usually expanded in primates
and especially in humans.
Are they neurogenic?
Do they actually make neurons?
And to test that we actually dissociated
cells from the progenitor zones,
labeled them with a virus marker
that actually just infected progenitors,
and then put a single progenitor in each
of multiwell plates.
And here's an example of a single one
of the progenitors in this well,
and a higher magnification view is there.
And then we time-lapse imaged the behavior
and you could identify
the outer radial glia
by their first division.
They put out a primary process
just like they would in situ,
and then they jumped and divided
and that made that cell classified
as an outer radial glia.
And we had other cells that rounded up
and divided, those were the
intermediate progenitors
and we looked seven weeks
later and culture it,
what the clones were like.
What does a single outer radial glial cell
actually produce at least in vitro?
And the answer was really surprising.
The cell I just showed
you after seven weeks
had produced a clone of at least 700 cells
which included neurons of both
deeper and upper cortical layers.
And in this clone there were no astrocytes
and some of the clones
that were additionally
astrocytes plus neurons.
And this is an enormous output of cells.
If we do the same experiment
with the radial glial cell in a mouse,
we get 20 to 40 cells after a month or so.
So, 700 to 1,000 cells from a single
outer radial glial cell
I think underscores
how enormously proliferative
these cells are.
And so, it helps support this model
which is still a work in progress
of what we think makes the human
cortical development
distinct say from the mouse.
And in the ventricular and
subventricular zone shown here
we think cells in the human
behave very much like the mouse,
but what makes the human so distinct
is the outer subventricular zone
which is filled with
these outer radial glia
that are born initially
from the ventricular zone and move away.
And they go through these
multiple self-renewing
asymmetrical divisions
producing these daughters,
shown here in green,
which are transit
amplifying progenitor cells.
And they actually divide
symmetrically at least twice.
We know they do that more than once
producing clones of cells
which then have the same birth date
and migrate therefore to
the same cortical layer.
And over time one of these
oRG cells will produce
multiple clones of cells
in multiple different layers.
And the radial fibers
support neuronal migration
so that allows an increase
in the cortical size
tangentially as well as radially.
So we think the cell is very important
for cortical expansion
both developmentally as shown here
and also in evolutionary terms.
But as I said we had no
markers for these cells.
We had no real idea of what
made them distinct molecularly
from the ventricular radial
glia for example in the mouse.
And so, we took as an approach for this
is single-cell RNA sequencing.
So we dissociated early cells shown here,
took those individual cells
and collected them in microliter
tiny little nano-sized
capture sites in a chip,
a microfluidic chip which is made by
Fluidigm Corporation.
And when they're captured
in these little sites
you can then do a lysis
and reverse transcription
and amplify them,
and then sequence the genes
for each individual cell.
And that's in an unbiased way.
That is we take all comers and see
what those gene differences look like.
And here's an example of a heat map
where we have the cells in all these rows
and genes in columns.
And you can see how they cluster
according to the genes that they express.
And that allows us to identify
molecular characteristics
of specific cell types.
And just to look at
some of the progenitors
and this is when we first
did our initial study
of about 300 cells that
were captured this way.
We can see three different cell states.
Here in the lower left are
the radial glial genes,
the ones that are most enriched
in radial glial cells.
In the brackets are the
intermediate progenitors
which are the daughters
of the radial glia.
And then here on the
right in the upper side
are the enriched genes mostly
in young immature neurons.
And what this shows us is that some genes
that are initially
expressed in the radial glia
persist in their daughter cells,
the intermediate progenitors.
And genes that are expressed
in those progenitors
persist as neurons are produced.
And this is very useful in a way
because it helps us watch
the lineage of these cells.
So example shown here actually confirms
what we saw from the time-lapse imaging.
Radial glial cells shown here on the Left
producing intermediate progenitors
that then generate neurons,
and these are some of the
genes both known and new genes
expressed at each of
these different stages.
We confirm the expression of the new genes
by in situ hybridization
shown here in slices.
Genes that we predict would
be expressed in radial glia
are located here at the ventricle.
The genes expressed in
intermediate progenitors
outer radial glia are expressed here.
And then the neural genes are expressed
in the cortical plate.
Now not only do this give us an idea of
the transition or lineage of cell types
but it gave us insight into
activated gene networks
that might actually be
signaling individual cell types.
And to focus on the outer
radial glia for this talk,
these are all schematically shown genes
that are coherent in networks
expressed exclusively by outer radial glia
at these early developmental stages.
And one of those gene
networks and pathways
is the LIFR/STAT3 signaling pathway
known to most stem cell biologists
as an important self-renewal pathway.
So we find that these
outer radial glial cells
are actually able to self renew themselves
and create their own niche.
If we inhibit this pathway as shown here
in these graphs on the lower right,
we significantly inhibit
the generation of the radial glial cells
but not the intermediate progenitors,
or for that matter, the
ventricular radial glia.
So it's selective to this one cell type
and it helps support an idea shown here
that distinguishes the
human from the mouse.
In the mouse as you know as we just heard,
they have radial glial cells
and intermediate progenitors
and the radial glial
cells line the ventricle
where they can receive
trophic factors signaling
from the CSF, cerebrospinal fluid.
In the outer subventricular zone
the cells have actually
moved away for the ventricle
and they're not able to access
the growth factors in the CSF,
but instead they developed
their own signaling pathways.
They can produce their own growth factors
and they create their own niche
for self renewal and expansion.
And we think that that is
one of the reasons of course
that these cells were able to undergo
the kind of prolonged
and massive proliferation
that I've shown you and that
Wieland mentioned just earlier.
We've also gotten some
insights into diseases
and I just wanna mention
two of them very quickly.
One of them is this.
And as I've just mentioned,
these outer radial glial
cells make their own niche
and they have factors
that promote self-renewal.
And when we looked at all
these genes in the literature
we found that they'd all
been reported earlier
or already discovered
in this particular kind of a tumor,
the glioblastoma multiforme
which is a terrible and inoperable
brain tumor found in
adults, not in children.
But when we look carefully
at the published single-cell
heat maps like this one
for radial glial genes,
rather for genes that
are expressed in tumors
as well as radial glia,
we cross those reference points.
We found that in fact that the
most aggressive glioblastomas
were enriched in the
same genes that we found
in the outer radial glial cells.
They had apparently an outer
radial glial cell signature
in the most aggressive
grade of glioblastoma.
So then we looked in surgical specimens
that we got from our colleagues at UCSF,
sectioned and stained and cultured them
just like we had a primary tissue.
And shown here are glioblastoma cells
from one of the patients
and I focus your attention on this cell
as it undergoes division.
I hope you can see it, yeah there it is.
Watch that one.
Here we go.
Right.
So you may have noticed
how it jumped and divided
exactly like the fetal cells do in situ.
So it looks as though we
have outer radial glial cells
in these glioblastomas and in fact,
that work is progressed to the point
where we now have good evidence
that these may be these cells of origin
for these very aggressive
glioblastoma tumors.
The next slide which has
to do with microcephaly
and microcephaly of course is a condition
where the brain is orders of magnitude
smaller than it would normally be.
And the most dramatic cases of this
occurred in Brazil last summer
when there was an outbreak
of Zika-induced microcephaly,
but initially it wasn't clear
that the Zika virus was
producing the microcephaly.
We were struck by the fact that
literature suggested there
was one specific factor
that mediated the entry of
the Zika virus into the skin,
and that was something
called the AXL receptor.
In our dataset from the outer radial glia
we've been talking
about on the other cells
in the developing brain is shown here
for all of the receptors known
to mediate entry of flaviviruses.
And the Zika virus uses
the ones shown here
with the black dots to
get into other cell types.
And I'll emphasize that the AXL receptor
which mediates Zika entry into other cells
is highly enriched but
only in certain cells
in our dataset.
Shown here it's enriched in astrocytes,
in radial glial cells,
not in intermediate
progenitors, not in neurons,
not an inter neurons.
And also in microglia and endothelium.
It has a very specific
pattern of expression
which we predicted might be the
tropism of the virus as well,
that as the virus would enter the cells
that express that receptor.
And so we managed in
collaboration with Joe DeRisi
to get active virus from a patient
who traveled to San Francisco from Brazil.
And he was donating blood
and the blood actually turned
out to have active virus.
So we cultured the virus
and exposed our tissue sections.
And shown here in green is the Zika virus
reproducing in cells in the
outer subventricular zone
which included the
outer radial glial cells
that I've been talking about.
It seems to be that they're
a very favorite target
of the Zika virus.
So, shown here in fact is the
outer radial glial cell packed
with the viral particles
just prior to rupture.
So these outer subventricular zone cells
are specifically and especially vulnerable
to infection with the Zika virus.
And when these patients
are born with microcephaly
it makes sense of course that
the neural progenitor cells
might be selectively affected.
And there's much more that goes on in this
devastating condition than just
infection of these outer radial glia,
but this seems to be part of the picture.
And we also took
advantage of the fact that
AXL we hypothesized was
mediating entry of the virus
to block it with a variety of different
chemicals and antibodies,
and shown here is an
example of a chemical block
of the AXL receptor.
And these are cultured human cells
that are exposed to the virus
and the green dots are the cells that are
actually infected with the virus.
And if you block the AXL
receptors shown here on the right
you can significantly reduce
the cells that get infected.
Confirming that the AXL receptors
is probably meeting entry into these,
at least these human cell types.
Now I was very interested
as I mentioned earlier
to find markers or
genes uniquely expressed
in these outer radial glia
that we could use as a tool
to try to learn more about the cell types.
And we're very gratified
in our first 300 cells
that we were able to do that.
Shown on the left are novel markers
that express themselves only
in the ventricular radial glia shown here.
And on the right are the
more interesting to me
novel gene markers that are expressed
in outer radial glia only.
And we justified or rather
we validated these markers
first by showing that they stain cells
with the morphology and
location of outer radial glia,
but also dynamically we watched cells
in our time-lapse imaging jump and divide.
And then we fixed them and
stained them with these markers
to confirm that the
cells that were jumping
were in fact expressing
these outer radial glial
markers and they were.
So this gives us now a
whole new set of tools
to start looking at these
outer radial glial cells.
One of the first things we noticed
challenges or I should say modifies
this classic model of human cortical
or primate cortical development
that Pasko Rakic proposed known as
the Radial Unit Hypothesis.
Very influential and still
very concise explanation
of how radial units form
and how they multiply over
time and also of evolution.
And I wanna emphasize the
radial glial scaffold here
which are all these fibers
go from radial glia down here
to the cortex along which neurons migrate.
And the model proposed
that this scaffold persists
throughout cortical development.
And we were struck when we had new markers
as I mentioned just a moment ago
that there seems to be a discontinuation
of the radial glial
fibers at later stages.
And that was evident from
these two cell markers.
In red I'm showing you HOPX
which is a gene expressed
throughout this outer
radial glial cell cytoplasm.
And you can see red
fibers that you can trace
all the way up to the pial surface.
In green is CRYAB which is a marker
that our data suggested was
only in ventricular radial glia,
and the green fibers only went up
to the outer subventricular zone
and never went further
at these later stages.
Suggesting that these fibers
and these fibers were discontinuous.
And we check that in a different way
by using Dil which is a lipophilic dye
that can be transported
along radial fibers.
And if we put those crystals on the top
or the bottom of this slice,
either way we were able to
show these continuous fibers
at ages up to around gestational week 16.
But beyond that picture
was quite different.
If we put Dil at the surface
it back-filled fibers only to
the outer subventricular zone
where they ended in
outer radial glial cells.
And if we put the Dil
at the ventricle it only
went generally as far as
the same outer subventricular zone,
suggesting a kind of a handoff of cells
from one zone to the other.
And that led to this
model which is a model
that suggests that the
second half of neurogenesis,
the upper cortical layers,
are produced by outer radial glia,
not by these ventricular radial glia
which now have transformed
into truncated radial glias.
We think there are three
kinds of radial glia
in cortical, in human
cortical development.
And we've now expanded
our single-cell analysis
to all these different cell types,
is given us an idea not only of
the diversity of cell
types that are produced
in the human brain compared to the mouse,
but we've also identified
unique markers for each of
these different cell types
at different stages of development
in different brain regions.
And one of them I wanna mention is DAB1
which is a Reelin effector.
It's found in radial glia at the ventricle
in the outer radial glia
but not in the truncated radial
glia which would be here.
And what's interesting
is that these two cells
have fibers that go all
the way up to the pia
where they can receive Reelin signaling
and the tRGs don't.
So it very nicely justifies or validates
the discontinuous glial scaffold model
that I showed you earlier.
And then I just wanted to summarize
the points that I've made so far
that the developmental evolution
of these three neural stem cell types,
the ventricular, outer
and truncated radial glia
we think help understand the expansion
and organization of cerebral cortex.
That the outer radial glial cells
are enriched in self-renewal
and proliferation genes
and that has led to some
disease-associated effects.
And that the mechanism
for human developmental
and evolutionary brain expansion
could be co-opted in
disorders like brain tumors
and could be targeted in
disorders such as microcephaly.
And finally I wanna thank all
the people who did the work
especially Aparna, Alex and Tom,
very gifted postdocs.
Alex and Tom are setting up
their own labs now at UCSF
and our sponsoring organizations.
Thank you for your attention.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)